[Music]
wanted to set the context with what are
the three key things we are going to
talk about what is engineering
productivity and what are we doing to
make high quality software development
easier and faster how do we do this by
adhering to our guiding principles of
driving test health avoiding performance
aggressions and ensuring high quality
releases and lastly Bengals talk back to
a lot of you who are DCP developers and
consumers what are we doing when it
comes to Antos which you heard sundar
talk about and a bunch of subsequent
keynotes what we are doing in terms of
engineering productivity with respect to
Antos and how you can benefit from that
what can you walk away from this talk in
terms of tools and infrastructure via
build which you can start using as soon
as you step out of this room so let's
get started
so Before we jump into things what do we
mean by moving fast and not breaking
things moving fast is good you know it
helps you innovate it helps you respond
to critical issues and bugs sooner it
enables better productivity because to
have a release chain which keeps going
constantly you have to follow the right
engineering practices and lastly it
really makes sure that code health is
prioritized for that particular service
or in our case the entire platform
because you cannot move fast if you keep
building technical debt but breaking
things isn't why is why is that bad
it's bad because it erodes user
satisfaction our customers who use GCB
are less likely to recommend GCP to
other customers if he constantly break
them it diminishes the brand GCP is used
by a bunch of critical companies and
applications and we need to make sure we
have a high uptime and high quality it
makes it hard for us internally as we
have seen a few years back when we
started this journey to really land our
features and commitments to the roadmaps
we have committed to our customers and
lastly quality stable stakes when it
comes to a cloud platform when you're
working with enterprise customers
quality stable six
so let's as an enterprise you need to
move fast the expected time for products
has moved from shorten dramatically from
years to days in a lot of cases but
again enterprise customers want quality
to Mithra and me a good analogy we could
think of was transportation and
high-speed trains you want to move fast
you want to get from point A to point B
as quickly as possible but not value
just safety of the passengers GCP is a
set of solutions and products that helps
our customers solve the toughest
business challenges we have external
paying customers who run their
applications at a massive scale on GCP
within Google and on GCP given its
open-source model we have a lot of
developers contributing to this platform
at all levels of the stack these
engineers want a seamless development
workflow and on deterministic signals
through the volatile flow process
a quick overview what is engineering
productivity um we started off as a text
engineering organization which was
focused mostly on the part of the
development workflow after code gets
submitted and how it gets validated
deployed and so on about a decade back
we started pivoting to engineering
productivity and we started looking at
the entire software development
lifecycle listicle II we realize it's
important for us to get involved right
from the design phase and to also make
sure that once our features products and
services are on production the actually
are performing scaling within Google we
use this term landing are they landing
it's not good enough to launch we want
to make sure things land we also started
as Google started getting involved in a
lot more things we started getting
involved with applications with the ML
nai space backends front-ends mobile and
we've been able to take a lot of the
learnings we've had within Google over
the last two decades
then take the best parts of it and
actually apply it to GCP and Antos so
let's first ground ourselves in some
numbers to give you all a idea of what
our engineering productivity is and how
it fits into GCP and within Google as
you can see on the slide Google has
about two billion lines of code and more
60k code submissions 800 cables 150
million automated tests more importantly
all of our tools are built in-house with
now we are starting to build them in
open source method we'll go into that
and they use the same technologies as
Google products do they run in the same
data centers szostak handles 2 million
QPS roughly so
the takeaway from this slide is it's
it's a massive scale so what does entrar
do as part of this to give hopefully all
of you recognize what this is if you use
if you're GCP customer you probably use
this this is the cloud console inch prod
works very closely with the cloud
console team to make sure we ship this
twice a week our goal is to establish
bi-weekly high quality release cadence
across GCP the console's at the higher
part of the stack it makes sense to ship
it twice a week
Allura storage systems core
infrastructure x' infrastructure systems
we don't want to ship down twice a week
but we do want to ship them with regular
cadence for the reasons I explained
before but we strongly believe that
internally we want to have as frequent
healthy snapshots in most cases like
daily release candidates as we call it
which gives us the ability to go faster
if we need to so how are we ensuring
this balancing developer velocity and
quality we have created a set of guiding
principles that let us balance developer
velocity and quality we want to share
these practices and tools with you all
so you can accelerate at the same pace
as we do we really pivoted on a
philosophy that we just don't want to be
comfortable prevent catching bugs we
want to prevent them this meant that in
addition to doing complex qualification
across systems we started building
tooling and infrastructure that enable
developers themselves to qualify the
code before they submitted going back to
the notion of preventing things
this changed the way we built qualified
deployed and monitored our applications
again to balance developer velocity and
quality let's look at what our guiding
principles are our guiding principles
are driving tests health avoiding
performance regressions ensuring high
quality releases all of which is
anchored in insightful and actionable
metrics let's take a closer look into
these principles and see what I'm
talking about the test health we aim for
hermetic integration tests first pre
summits and elimination of tests
flakiness internally we have built a
cloud integration testing framework that
incorporates these learnings and
principles and enables developers to
write tests once and run them anywhere
I'm going to repeat that write tests
once run them anywhere that is important
because that has allowed us to really
amplify the value of our tests and
because the tests are hermetic they are
fast they don't have flakiness and that
has really boosted our ability to
increase the amount of validation we can
do for a feature right from the time it
starts getting developed to even how it
performs in production under the hood we
have a bunch of technologies like
resource pre provisioning record replay
to speed up setup and teardown which for
those of you are in this space know
takes up a lot of the time when it comes
to integration test so let's look at our
next guiding principle avoiding
performance regressions we want to make
performance a first-class citizen we
have done that by building a performance
benchmarking library internally that
service owners and products can
seamlessly integrate into their products
and get rich performance benchmarks this
is now a standard not only within GCB
but within google this earn turn has
allowed us to keep monitoring
performance as a feature or a service
keeps getting developed and not as
afterthought once we put it on
production and then figure out oh it
doesn't scale or it's slow lastly a
third principle ensuring high quality
releases we wanted to take this slide as
an opportunity to say that there's a
balance between tooling and process as
much as effective tooling is important
and we have built a bunch of great
tooling in this space I think we've
learned that effective process is
important when it comes to high quality
releases we have distilled the problem
on GC be that if the rate at which we
push our features from development to
production if you're doing that well
you're ensuring high quality releases we
have learned a bunch of best practices
we wanted to share a few of them with
you all here one of the most important
things we realize is if you decouple the
features and the binaries that really
helps your binaries and your releases to
be a release chain one that goes out
every day every week depending on the
service and if there is a certain
problem that shows up in production it's
mostly guarded behind a feature flag you
can just turn off the flag and the
releases keep going out
this also helps us really install the
engineering discipline we need for the
last bullet here if there is a problem
introduced not by a particular feature
there is some global state in the
architecture we have the culture to
figure out what caused the problem debug
it find our exact change reverted
cherry-pick the change that caused the
problem let the train keep going and go
fix it and put it in the next train
this ensures that we are not taking
shortcuts for critical fixes critical p0
s and so on and so forth most
importantly we measure all of these wire
metrics I read this somewhere literally
half an hour back I thought it was good
to share it here if you don't know where
you come from you don't know where you
are if you don't know where you are you
don't know where you're going if you
don't know where you're going you're
probably going somewhere wrong that
brings me to project health V balance
developer velocity and quality at Google
and on GCP why a project health which we
refer to as pH we track key metrics
across developer productivity release
velocity reliability and most
importantly quality we automatically
calculate a project health level a pH
level based on all these metrics we have
years of data at Google and within GCP
that a higher projects project head
level is the better they do at balancing
developer velocity and quality
a higher ph means better development
practices a higher ph means a better
ability to fix issues a higher ph means
you're following your focus you can
focus on coding and not pushing releases
because they are automatically going on
and so on and so forth
let me ground this with a concrete
example here's an example of a project
health dashboard for a particular area
in GCP this is the view the service area
gets saying these are all your projects
here's your overall project health level
this gives them an ability to zoom into
one of these areas and figure out which
one of these metrics they are struggling
in and what they need to devote their
resources on as engineering productivity
this is also very useful information for
us because very often there are a lot
more developers working on a service
than engineering productive and
productivity engineers working with that
service so this helps us prioritize our
efforts and figure out what are the hot
spots for this particular product or
area and zoom in on that so recapping
guiding principles are driving tests
health avoiding performance regressions
make performance of us class citizen not
an afterthought ensure high quality
releases both my effective tooling and
process and engineering discipline and
measure everything I didn't invite me
through now to talk about what we are
doing along these principles when it
comes to Antos the tools we have build
and how you all can benefit from them
hi everyone the outside world now uses
VMs kubernetes github and containers
Google software traditionally used to be
stored in a single shared repository but
our landscape is continuously changing
and we need to evolve to adapt to this
changing landscape as we were building
tooling for anthos and further on so
let's look at open source development
Google works very closely with
kubernetes and Estia open source
communities to develop a lot of tools to
improve development velocity as well as
quality we contribute very actively to
suggesting in kubernetes let us dig a
little bit deeper into the test
infrastructure along the same guiding
principles that you'd saw and get talked
about just now driving test health in
the open source community for kubernetes
we helped build the continuous
integration system called brow brow
started in 2016 and we replace Jenkins
as the system for kubernetes why is this
important because we can no be no longer
need to run a Jenkins master and we can
update the service without any downtime
another important thing is that we test
kubernetes on kubernetes it is very easy
to maintain and deploy and respond to
github web hooks rather than using a
manager test grid so test crate provides
a grid of test results which gives you
very fast access to test results you can
also highly configure this to look at
all the bug data and sort through data
and get like data about grouping or
filing bugs and so on this is integrated
with cloud build and so you can go to
results store to view all of the cloud
build results and logs and do more
analysis on the data let us see what we
have done in the space of hermetic
infrastructure when it comes to open
source some of you may be familiar with
kubernetes and docker
this is another open source tool
available for use to you in kubernetes
this provides a hermetic testing via a
local kubernetes cluster
you can run on your development
workstation there are no external
dependencies and it helps you
integration test kubernetes applications
with other things like sto or Nomos and
so on let's see a quick demo of how kind
works in action I'll give you a second
to absorb this yeah as you can see the
cluster gets created really quickly and
basically creates an entire kubernetes
cluster in the matter of seconds then
you compared it to a cluster on cloud
which takes about four to five minutes
to start up avoiding performance
regressions we want to make performance
a first-class citizen like UNK it was
just talking about we want to provide
you the ability to visualize performance
data and catch regressions really
quickly and so we are working on open
sourcing tooling that lets you visualize
performance data and find these
regressions just as we do for GCP this
graph shows the trend for a performance
benchmark and you can see that there is
a developer checking in a fix and then
that caused the performance regression
to be fixed and then the the curve came
down again and this kind of lets
developers collaborate with each other
around performance we've already
deployed this to some of our customers
and we are working to bring this to open
source talking about high quality
releases I wanted to highlight how
Jenkins X uses prowl for CI CD alongside
the Canadian built pipelines let's walk
through the process a little bit a
developer creates a PR the github github
then sends the PR notification to prowl
prowl creates a build on Canada and it
runs the Jenkins file pipeline and the
results get uploaded to results store so
this is one of the ways that you can
automate your full CI CD pipeline using
prowl and Jenkins X on open source and
let's take a look at actionable metrics
kubernetes was essential
designed for software portability and
like developer portability today to kind
of ensure consistency and portability
when we move across cloud providers and
Club we worked with kubernetes for the
CN CF which is cloud native compute
foundation as you might know and help
design or implement the conformance
program this infrastructure lets you
measure the end-to-end coverage when it
comes to a kubernetes api s-- and
visualize the results of coverage over
time this is all integrated into test
grids so you can view the coverage
numbers for kubernetes api s-- we've
also enabled this for Canadia and so
here you can see a graph that shows you
how the coverage numbers trend over time
and you can see the results on test grid
and then moving on to a hybrid cloud
model with Antos we wanted to make sure
that as the landscape evolves to support
hybrid cloud and multi cloud we use the
same CI CD and tooling processes to also
test a hybrid cloud platform so we use
the make use of the same CI and CD
systems with prowl results tour and so
on and make sure that we can also test
on Prem the same way we test on GC P
let's take a little bit of a closer look
at the qualification pipeline for anthos
so developer has code in his repository
and this is the system under test so we
want to make sure that you are testing
your pre submit flows and submitting the
code when code gets submitted a git
checkout happens and we run an on-prem
cluster of brow on a vSphere lab and
then this creates a gke cluster runs all
the tests and then publishes the test
results to test grid
once the developer submits the code we
also run tests on post submit certain
tests are run pre submit and some on
post summon and you can basically see
how prowl again runs the tests and
publishes the results to test great so
this helps us really easily interpret
the CI signal towards release readiness
so to summarize again
engineering productivity makes quality
software development easier and faster
and we do this by adhering to our
guiding principles of driving test
health avoiding performance regression
and ensuring high quality releases and
you saw a little bit about anthos
engineering productivity tools and how a
lot of them are available for your use
and benefit
[Music]